von den pagoden maß für den hochhäusern
singapurs von den ehemaligen
schlachtfeldern kambodschas ins
pulsierende jakarta
640 millionen menschen darunter muslime
christen buddhisten und taoisten und
konfusion ist in thailand malaysia die
philippinen und vietnam asian gehört zu
den komplexesten regionen der welt
es ist unglaublich vielfältig bietet so
viel potenzial für handel und
verbundenheit die wirtschaft von asian
ist insgesamt so groß wie die indians
die chancen sind gewaltig ebenso jedoch
die herausforderungen
grenzen verlieren gerade in dieser
region an bedeutung
südostasien steht am scheideweg
eine aufstrebende wirtschaftsmacht der
in zukunft von wichtigen entscheidungen
abhängt die die gesamte nächste
generation in asien prägen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin hess länder armin unsere
reise beginnt in thailand wo asian vor
über 50 jahren entstand
fünf länder die sich zum schutz vor dem
kommunistischen china verbündeten
seitdem hat sich viel geändert
vietnam myanmar und kambodscha sind in
schwierigen zeiten beigetreten die
wirtschaftsleistung der region wächst
seit zehn jahren jedes jahr um 5
die größte errungenschaft war es die
vielfältigste region des planeten zu
vereinen
640 millionen menschen darunter muslime
christen buddhisten
maoisten und konfusion ist
frieden und wohlstand zu erwirken wirkte
nirgends unwahrscheinlicher als
[Musik]
wir sind weit gekommen darunter bleibe
ich optimistisch die schwarzmaler sagt
natürlich es gehe nichts voran oder
nicht weit genug
aber wenn man sich erreger den personen
und güterverkehr sowie den handel
innerhalb von asian ansieht sieht man
große fortschritte
darum bin ich sehr optimistisch
die finanzbranche ist nicht in allen
ländern gleich ausgereift es
unterscheidet sich den rahmenbedingungen
entsprechend
für grenzübergreifende finanzintegration
werden wir wohl einiges standardisieren
müssen
wir müssen nicht alle auf den gleichen
standard kommen aber die standards der
länder müssen für grenzüberschreitende
geschäfte miteinander kompatibel sein
[Musik]
ich bin in thailand das ist mir einmal
und dort ist laos unter uns der mächtige
mekong der bis nach vietnam fließt diese
region bekannt für den opiumhandel ist
nur ein kleines puzzleteil von asian
die zehn mitgliedstaaten unterscheiden
sich drastisch
von indonesien mit der größten
muslimischen bevölkerung der welt bis
zum kleinen brunner die politische und
religiöse vielfalt ist gewaltig die 640
millionen bewohner von asien stellen
neun prozent der weltbevölkerung
die wirtschaftsleistung von 2,8
billionen dollar ist ebenso groß wie die
von frankreich großbritannien oder
indien
[Musik]
es gibt hier sehr reiche länder wie
singapur und brunei
aber auch arme länder wie laos und
kambodscha
sie gehören derselben organisation an
große länder wie indonesien mit 270
millionen einwohnern und singapur mit
fünf millionen
somit ergänzen sich die länder von asian
aufgrund der kosten durch zölle und der
transport geschwindigkeit ist die
vereinigung noch nicht abgeschlossen
sie muss hier schnell aufholen sonst
werden china und indien den
online-handel und die handelswege
dominieren
scheint es manchmal die länder asiens
würden mehr miteinander konkurrieren als
kooperieren
die frage stellt sich durchaus wollen
sie es zu bejahen
man sieht das auch in china dort
konkurrieren die provinzen manchmal
untereinander bei asian findet es auf
nationaler ebene statt und es daher noch
intensiver
ein meilenstein der starken gruppe war
2015 die einrichtungen der asian
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft asien
ziel der es ist ein einheitlicher markt
der sich in die weltwirtschaft einfügt
für den warenhandel ist es quasi ein
einziger markt
es gibt aber noch finanzielle hürden die
wir überwinden müssen
ich arbeite seit über 20 jahren in der
asse und den verhandlungen dieses
abkommens
wenn ich mir die errungenschaften aus
diesen 20 jahren ansehe bin ich doch
sehr zufrieden damit
der unterschied ist die sichtweise ist
das glas halb leer oder halb voll ich
würde sagen im vergleich zu unserem
ausgangspunkt ist es halb voll
ich hätte gerne einen einheitlichen
markt und bewegungsfreiheit für
arbeitskräfte was für zehn jahre
vielleicht etwas zu viel verlangt ist
wenn wir aber den einheitlichen markt
haben warum sollte nicht eray 100
prozent aller airlines in asien besitzen
sie an sollte seinen bürgern auf
vielerlei art nutzen
finanzintegration
wirtschaftsintegration
handels integration
das ziel ist eine einheitliche politik
wirtschaftlicher nachhaltigkeit
grenzen verlieren gerade in dieser
region an bedeutung
zu dieser jahreszeit sind weite gebiete
im norden thailands myanmar und laos von
rauch verhüllte
landwirte brennen nach der ernte ihre
felder ab der ertrag wird in kleinen
betrieben wie diesen verpackt
kleinunternehmen den anschluss zur
vierten industriellen revolution zu
ermöglichen ist eine der größten
herausforderungen von asian die kosten
von finanzdienstleistungen sinken durch
den tag und allgemeine technologie
drastisch
nicht nur können wir viel mehr menschen
bankdienstleistungen und versicherungen
ermöglichen sondern auch menschen in
entlegenen gebieten
darum sind smartphones so wichtig denn
sie verändern unsere
finanzdienstleistungen grundlegend
das ist das geniale an asian
asian ist die unvollkommen sste
organisation der welt wenn man bei asian
genau hinsieht machen wir zwei schritte
nach vorn einen zurück und einen zur
seite wie eine krabbe die im kreis läuft
über jahrzehnte beobachtet wird asien
aber immer stärker und stärker ein grund
ist die flexibilität von asia unser
konsens prinzip leistet uns gute dienste
denn es ist sehr flexibel
es ist unvorstellbar dass 440 millionen
menschen in asien keine bankkonten haben
das ist unser nächstes thema bei asian
the next generation
willkommen zurück in südostasien gibt es
viele kleine unternehmen wie diese in
manchen ländern stellen sie 90 prozent
aller arbeitsplätze
dennoch haben weiterhin gewaltige 440
millionen menschen kein bankkonto
das sind mehr menschen als die
bevölkerung der usa und deutschlands
zusammen
man will die banken lose bevölkerung
erschließen doch bisher ist das
schwierig da oft nur die menschen mit
schlechten bank zugang erreicht werden
warum
es geht um verschiedene dinge wenn es
darum geht die banken lose oder
unterversorgt der bevölkerung zu
erreichen muss es klare richtlinien für
die arten von produkten und bereichen
geben die wir bewerben möchten
in thailand ist die
haushaltsverschuldung hoch und manche
teile der bevölkerung sind ebenfalls
hoch verschuldet
darum brauchen wir find ick und
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit krediten
um bessere versorgung zu vernünftigen
preisen zu gewährleisten
mit neuen technologien die nicht mehr
probleme für sie erschaffen und ihre
finanzielle lage weiter die
stabilisieren
ich halte die kreditwürdigkeit und
garantie programme von rating agenturen
für eine mögliche lösung
wie wir kleinunternehmer unterstützen
und ihnen den zugang zu
finanzdienstleistungen ermöglichen
können
gleichzeitig halte ich digitale
finanzlösungen auch für eine möglichkeit
für kleinunternehmer im finanzwesen
teilzunehmen da die informationen hier
bei genauer sind und sie so zugang
erhalten könnten
die finanzielle inklusion ist nicht in
allen ländern gleich weit
fortgeschritten
in thailand entspricht die schwierigkeit
ein girokonto zu bekommen in etwa
normalen standards
bei auslandsüberweisungen haben wir
sorgen
die gebühren für auslandsüberweisungen
nach und aus thailand sind mit die
höchsten der welt
das wollen wir ändern und finn tech und
andere neue technologien können uns
dabei helfen mehr und mehr menschen am
markt teilhaben zu lassen
für händler in myanmar und reisbauern in
kambodscha für geschäfte in hanoi manila
und jakarta und bangkok eröffnet in taek
eine völlig neue welt
doch geht es dabei immer wieder um die
gleichen kern thema nachhaltigkeit
verletzung und inklusion wie stellen sie
sicher dass länder wie kambodscha und
vietnam nicht abgehängt werden
zuallererst wird man hat wirklich große
fortschritte gemacht
als das inklusiv groove programm begann
bekam in kambodscha laos und myanmar die
finanzierungshilfen für
infrastrukturprojekte zu günstigeren
konditionen
wir brauchen derartige praktische
initiativen
auch die ausbildung und umschulung die
gesamte berufsbildung wird so gefördert
das sind alles praktische maßnahmen
auch dass die kosten strukturell in
diesen ländern geringer sind als in
anderen asian staaten zieht seinerseits
investoren an
begrüßte die digitalisierung mit offenen
armen
ist der rest der region ebenfalls bereit
für die vierte industrielle revolution
wir sind etwas im rückstand aber wir
holen auf
mit der einzigartigen tech branche von
indonesien der verwendung von weiber in
den philippinen
bruder von laien in thailand und dem
wachsenden online-handel sowie der
wachsenden vernetzung durch
mobiltelefone und apps liegen wir nicht
mehr weit zurück
ich sage immer man muss groß denken sie
an muss in der technologiewelt groß
denken
unser rückstand ist nicht groß die
bildung muss noch aufholen und wir
müssen die menschen hier ausbilden um
unser humankapital richtig zu nutzen
ich glaube asien wird sich sehr schnell
anpassen sobald sich eine gelegenheit
dazu ergibt
ich denke wir können ein paar plätze
gutmachen wenn wir uns in einigen
bereichen anpassen
[Musik]
die integration benachbarter asian
länder ist ein wichtiger schritt der
2015 durch die es ihm möglich wurde
dadurch erhöhte sich das wachstum des
bruttoinlandprodukts erheblich es stieg
von 1200 dollar pro einwohner vor 20
jahren auf fast
4300 dollar
das ist für die finanzielle integration
sehr wichtig
wie schwierig wird die finanzintegration
dadurch dass sich die mitgliedstaaten in
sachen entwicklung so drastisch
unterscheiden
dadurch dass sie auf unterschiedlichen
entwicklungsstufen stehen ergänzen die
staaten einander einige staaten wie
singapur malaysia und thailand
erwirtschafteten überschüsse während
andere länder geld brauchen so können
wir einander unterstützen und ergänzen
[Musik]
kann die produktivität aller asien
staaten verbessern
finanzsysteme in asien sind stark
verbesserungsfähig und technologie kann
hier eine große rolle spielen
inter kann die finanzielle inklusion
verbessern da die kosten für
finanzdienstleistungen drastisch sinken
werden
zehn länder mit eigenen kulturen
sprachen und religionen
alle auf anderen entwicklungsstufen
gibt es dennoch eine gemeinsame asien
identität
das werden wir als nächstes herausfinden
[Musik]
in den ersten 50 jahren ging es beim
projekt asian vornehmlich um die
verständigung der regierungen und ihre
zusammenarbeit jetzt geht es darum den
menschen von asien ein gefühl der
zugehörigkeit zu vermitteln es freut
mich dass asien hier die europäische
union nachahmt wie man in europa eine
eigene fahne sieht sieht man hier ebenso
die landesfahne unternehmen die fahne
von asian gibt es denn eine asian
identität in der frage herrscht keine
einigkeit
ich glaube nicht dass es so etwas gibt
und ich bin überzeugter asien ist warum
nicht es geht darum was asian seinen
einfachen bürgern bedeutet
wir müssen stärker an unserer marke
arbeiten zeigen dass asian jeden
einzelnen etwas angeht es wird wohl oft
eher als bedrohung denn als chance
wahrgenommen
in bezug auf die asian identität wird
viel unternommen gerade im
soziokulturellen bereich das ergänzt
sich mit der finanziellen und
wirtschaftlichen integration
mit wachsendem handel und zunehmenden
tourismus wird sich das wechselseitige
verständnis und die wertschätzung
innerhalb der asien gruppe stark
verbessern
gibt es eine asien identität
in vielerlei hinsicht ja wir mögen über
600 millionen menschen seien mit
verschiedenen sprachen kulturen und
identitäten
aber andererseits sind wir gleichzeitig
auch alle ein sehr gelassenes fall
das ist ein vorteil durch den wir besser
zusammenarbeiten können
es geht aber nicht nur um identität
sondern auch mobilität sie ist eine der
größten herausforderungen in asia arbeit
waren und geld müssen fließen über diese
grenze kommen die menschen aus myanmar
jeden tag nach thailand um zu arbeiten
und zu handeln aber in asien stellen
grenzen oft auch hindernisse für
geschäftsbeziehungen dar
[Musik]
in thailand gibt es über drei millionen
gastarbeiter aus myanmar ihr geld nach
myanmar zu schicken ist für sie sehr
teuer an der grenze wird auf den
naturalien gehandelt weil es so teuer
ist geld über die grenze hinweg in
andere länder zu senden und zu empfangen
intec kann hier helfen die finanzielle
inklusion deutlich zu verbessern
grenzen sind verarbeiter ein großes
problem wie können wir das problem lösen
und standardisieren
das ist ein heikles thema denn der freie
fluss von arbeitskraft steht letztlich
nicht zur debatte
nicht alle sind gleichermaßen bereit
menschen mit bestimmten qualifikationen
und angehörigen bestimmter berufe diese
mobilität zu gewähren
daran arbeiten wir die arbeitsmärkte
sind in ganz asien auf verschiedenen
entwicklungsstufen
wir müssen uns daher darauf
konzentrieren die verschiedenen
ökonomien zu integrieren durch den
handel mit waren sowie dienstleistungen
und durch investitionen
wenn wir in verschiedenen teilen von
asien wachstum schaffen können können
die menschen in allen ländern
angemessene gute arbeit haben
auf der anderen seite müssen wir mit den
zentralbanken zusammenarbeiten wobei wir
gute fortschritte bei der nutzung
lokaler währungen für handel und
investitionen sehen konnten
vor zwei jahren begannen die bank of
thailand und die bank negara malaysia
die nutzung von thailändischen baht und
malaysischen ringgit für handel und
investitionen zu fördern
seit letztem jahr ist die zentralbank
von indonesien als dritter partner dabei
dadurch nähern sich die wechselkurse der
währungen einander an somit haben
unternehmen in der region eine echte
wahl und die wechselkurse und gebühren
sie
in verschiedenen teilen von asien sieht
die zukunft heißt sie anders aus für die
großen unternehmen und großen städte
geht es nicht nur um den austausch über
asien grenzen hinweg sondern um den
globalen markt sich millionen kleine bis
mittlere unternehmen benötigen generell
zugang zu märkten
arbeiter suchen arbeit wo sie können
eltern suchen bildung für ihre kinder
das ist ein grund warum asien eine der
vielfältigsten und komplexesten regionen
der welt ist
was ist ihre vision für asien
wir hoffen dass asien weiter sicherheit
wohlstand und zufriedenheit bietet
das wir weiter jede woche das
wohlergehen der menschen in asien
verbessern können
die ganze arbeit für die wirtschaftliche
und finanzielle integration die
förderung von find ick unter gleichen
alles dient letztlich dem ziel das
wohlergehen der menschen in asien zu
verbessern
so wollen wir frieden und stabilität in
asien waren und zu frieden und wohlstand
auf der welt beitragen
wir sollten beachten was wir im westen
beobachten können
wenn der wohlstand in asien steigt
werden auch nachfrage und vielfalt
weiter wachsen
dadurch könnte sich die gesellschaft
spalten und soziale aspekte wie die
wohlstands verwaltung ein immer
wichtigeres thema werden
asien sollte sich bewusst werden was
unsere stärken und was unsere schwächen
sind
einige länder haben offensichtliche
spezialisierungen die sich von anderen
land unterscheiden singapur wird nie
eine große agra nation aber es hat eine
sehr starke finanzinfrastruktur
die länder sollten also nicht
zwangsläufig andere imitieren sondern
ihre eigene nische finden
wirtschaftlich tut sich immer mehr es
gibt gemeinsame probleme die wir
bewältigen müssen und technologie wird
die grenzen zwischen den ländern
verschwimmen lassen
es geht also darum dass alle profitieren
und dass wir mit dem integrations
netzwerk von asian wachstum und
nachhaltigen wohlstand für alle bürger
in asien fördern
asien sollte vorsichtiger und
pragmatische vorgehen die arbeiter
ströme lenken
wenn ich mich nicht irre arbeiten
bereits millionen indonesia in malaysia
in singapur arbeiten 1,7 millionen
ausländer in diesem stadtstaat auf einer
insel
in thailand gibt es viele gastarbeiter
aus miramar
arbeitskräfte sind ständig im fluss aber
eine echte bewegungsfreiheit wie in der
europäischen union ist nirgendwo in
sicht
mein traum für asien wäre ein
fortwährender zusammenhalt dass wir
nicht aufgrund der wachsenden rivalität
zwischen den usa und china zerbrechen
die sorge wie asian diesen gewaltigen
wettstreit zwischen den usa und china in
den kommenden zehn zwanzig jahren
überstehen kann bereitet mir schlaflose
nächte
von der quelle bis zum meer liegt der
mekong mehr als 4000 kilometer zurück
und ist seit jahrhunderten die
verbindende lebensader in diesem teil
der welt der wandel ist jedoch nicht
aufzuhalten
gewaltige infrastrukturprojekte und die
digitale revolution erschaffen eine
völlig neue zukunft danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit bei asian bei next
generation
[Musik]